well fabiano needed an armageddon a
playoff but irena crush did not need any
of that just cruised through the
championship bracket irena first of all
congratulations
how do you feel about this match it
didn't seem like even in the second game
there was no pressure coming from your
opponent
yeah i know i feel very happy and more
happy than about the extra five thousand
dollars that alejandro mentioned i'm
happy about the free day
tomorrow because you know honestly it's
i think it's a bit like a disastrous
scenario imagine you lose instead of
getting a free day you got to prepare
for a rapid match you don't have any
free days in the tournament so i mean
that was definitely something valuable
to me something that was much more
interested in uh achieving
that day of rest and just um yeah that
works out perfectly so yeah this game um
it was pretty much under control i think
it's some interesting thing
psychologically going on in the opening
right
because she played this move bishop g5
now i don't know
if they had uh you know
she and whoever is you know helping her
prepare like if they had guessed that i
might go for this semis uh for this
[ __ ] right it would be hard to guess
that given that i've never you know i
haven't played this in years
um but she played bishop g5 and i i
think like psychologically that's a good
decision i mean i agree with that like
that she veered away from something that
she's been doing more recently to try
this one out but you know i had given
this also some thought so what i was
gonna do and um
and uh yeah the preparation that i did
last night it turned uh quite useful did
you consider taking on c4 and going into
any of those crazy bad finnick lines or
cambridge springs was on d7 was decided
before last night
i had to you know have that kind of
question answered
because you know i saw she had used to
play this move bishop g5 it's not out of
the question that she could return to it
and i think in a situation where you
gotta win i think it was just the right
choice um and she played it very quickly
so i think it'd be interesting to ask
her you know
was that something they expected um this
kind of opening for me but
anyway we went into this i mean she
already had some games in this about
like a year or so ago
um
and and yeah i mean it was just
important i think like this move e5 was
really important this was my first real
think of the game when i realized you
know actually i can do this move it's a
pretty good moment to do it
exactly
and i was feeling you know quite
comfortable about my position because
often these positions the bishop goes
back to f8 and i hadn't yet brought him
back so he's actually very useful on a3
not not allowing white to
um fight for the c file and basically my
approach was like try to be as specific
as possible because when you need a draw
to advance you don't want to play a long
game with like you know nothing really
determines like you want to find those
forcing options and when i played queen
a4 i had seen this line with knight c5
94
and i
calculated it again to make sure that it
was okay
of course it's a little dangerous when
you give up
a piece here there's an interesting move
um rook c3 after pawn takes c4
um yeah no no keep going yeah so yeah d6
up right here rook c3
i don't know if she considered this but
i was like huh
she can give up another pawn try to get
that rook over now i i kind of believe
that i should have a defense there that
like it wasn't so bad because her rook
and f1 is not taking part in the attack
but there's still there's still
something going on i mean there's g6
there's also h6 actually you know yeah
so i couldn't just
um say challenge yeah go ahead take the
take take the pawn because i don't i
think my king is getting away
it doesn't look that dangerous does it
yeah the bishop's hanging a bit but
but other than that there's not really
anything but it's an intriguing thought
that rook c3 suddenly yeah and like your
king has no
defenders remarkable
idea she played
the normal and i think that uh
she seemed to miss queen f5 or when she
played this whole line uh i don't know
though after rook d1 queen d7 there's
almost not i mean like there's nothing
really that white is threatening right
black is just up a pawn
so
she had to go into this uh ending which
is interesting because if she goes
bishop e3 i go bishop b8 right exactly
um i actually keep my pawn and there's
really no danger
with the bishop on b8 i'm not going to
give up you know the a7 pawn so easily
we thought that this might be her last
chance to try to keep anything alive but
even
this position seems to be quite safe for
you yeah i mean at some point i just go
e4 open up the bishop and yeah so yeah
that was um i think actually the game
got a lot more exciting than i wanted
yeah really yeah yeah no no this is not
even the the excitement that we had on
the board was not supposed to happen
like really when did because we thought
you kind of cruising and more or less
keeping i felt like no actually i
thought first of all i thought her move
queen d1 was very clever like if we go
back to this moment right it looks like
nothing is going on right but the thing
is queen d1 she has ideas of like queen
b1 and rook d1 and suddenly
orchestrating these like back rank ideas
and there's so many ways i can like you
know blunder rook with a check or
blender the h5 pawn so no i didn't find
this like easy at all in fact i felt
like this this was like the hardest part
of the game for me wow
okay
but you kept your composure you kept it
all together and uh
now you're
the champions of the champions bracket
how does it feel yeah it feels really
good yes i'm happy and i'm uh you know i
feel like this was a good um first part
of the tournament and now i get a little
break and i just want to
continue that
wonderful arena well congratulations
congratulations i'm definitely very
impressed with her chess if that was
i mean she's had no dangerous positions
right in the tournament except for that
moment against begging a couple of
rounds ago